like you got to choose the business
model that's right for you but answer
the question of like okay can this
audience that i have
make me a billionaire
[Music]
i have one house that's
gonna pull off like 15 000 a month and
it's just a single house
so
you'll beat it by quite a bit no way
really what's what's the house worth
uh i bought it for 900k
that's right
dude that's crazy 700 a night
where where is it
yeah
uh it's in in boise uh like right next
to the boise state university stadium
oh so do you get like basically like
football tourists or what do you who
who's renting this thing for 700 a night
in boise
we're live by the way nathan we're live
great no for real
um
who's renting it so you get like all
graduation everyone coming in to you
know tour the university or whatever
else and then um
uh
just anyone coming to downtown it's like
a five bedroom brand new construction
sam it actually looks like the kitchen
looks somewhat similar to uh the place
you just linked me to so
so why haven't you bought some more like
floating shelves in the tile backsplash
and all that why haven't you bought like
yeah in the same area that's my question
yeah it's a million dollars it's a
million dollar or 900 000 or whatever
you said under a million dollar house
that's making
20 15 grand a month why don't you buy 50
of them
well i i i just bought this one and so
it's not making that yet but that's what
we're like the bookings for the summer
so
it's at i just did 8 000 for
january locked in
um and then the summer bookings are
coming in at like quite a bit higher um
like so the january ones you know are
last minute and and boise is slow there
but uh
yeah the summer ones are coming in at
eight nine a thousand dollars a night
eight hundred nine hundred or a thousand
a night um which is wild and we haven't
put a hot tub on it yet so i just bought
a hot tub today and uh
so we'll get that in there i should be
able to charge a little bit more and
it's gonna be good
wow so we should start uh we should
intro intro
well yeah so you're we're live that
might go live this is nathan barry
nathan barry um i've known nathan since
a gum road meetup shawn i went to a
gumroad meetup in like for real uh i'm
not joking she doesn't join that sounds
maybe 2012 2013. nathan was doing
gumroad he had this book called
authority right authority yep
and i don't even remember what the book
was about just making a living online
but then you also had graphic design
stuff and you had a really cool blog and
you uh you sold all types of stuff but
i've been homies with you for a while
and then you launched this thing called
convertkit and i was like nathan like
the other thing's working just do that
and anyway
now it's a business that both sean and i
i think are i didn't end up i didn't end
up doing it there's some
mechanics problem with the way we can
get into it we're an llc in it it gets
complicated uh
as like pass-through funds and stuff
like that but yeah
but sam you're okay
i'm in the cool club and basically his
business convertkit does like 26 i think
million dollars in recurring revenue
it's like a mailchimp competitor that's
better and different their their revenue
is all completely live so if you google
convertkit revenue yeah like 20 the
revenue
29. do you regret now that your business
is actually kicking ass do you feel like
i kind of wish this wasn't all super
transparent or
you know because it's good early on
transparency is great early on it gets
you a bunch of people interested then
when you start winning
you know you're giving more value than
you're getting back usually by that by
doing that
yeah so i think it's uh a great idea if
it's for a mission reason a terrible
idea if it's for like a marketing reason
and i actually had two friends who sat
me down at one point and they're like
nathan this is an intervention take down
your like public
metrics page
and
which they were right like
they had talked to competitors who were
like wow this is so helpful like you're
scrolling through and they're like you
know your competitors are doing this
right i'm like i know but really it's
like uh it's a mission thing of the
whole mission for the company is help
creators earn a living and so if we can
put this public blueprint out there
that's not just like the snapshot of
time where you know you've done it with
companies where you're going through and
you're like oh they said here they're at
10 million you know you're like trying
to piece together the trajectory
we all have the same spreadsheets um
and so
like actually doing it in real time
means that someone can be like okay i'm
at 50k mrr
churn is absolutely brutal right now oh
i wonder what convertkit's churn was
when they were at 50k right and you can
go back and you can find the date range
and be like oh in this time here's all
of their metrics here's how fast they're
growing and everything and so it's like
this
for anyone who wants it it's this master
class where you have to dig in and find
the data but you can find everything
about our business and my hope is that
it's like breadcrumbs that every future
entrepreneur who wants to how much
recreation how much traffic does
hopefully in another industry
do you know what's up how much traffic
does that page get
i don't know it's not actually even our
page it's convertkit.baremetrics.com
right and uh
it's not even ours so wow
presumably not that much okay so you're
for real not using it for marketing if
you don't even know how much traffic it
gets okay now i believe you but when you
said the mission thing
i have a i have a system of uh tuning
out whenever anybody says values mission
vision things like that i'm just like
yeah by default i do not believe
anything you're about to say for the
next 30 seconds
how many um how many people work there
now
because when you
you wrote this blog post two years i
forget i've been reading your blog for
so long i don't remember the years but
you wrote a blog post and you're like oh
we are making let's say eight million
dollars a year but we basically had
twenty thousand dollars in the bank or
that's i don't remember the exact
numbers but it was almost as extreme as
that right
yeah so
uh the company's totally self-funded
there's no outside capital and so when
we hit like this period of rapid growth
we grew from 2000 a month to 100 000 a
month in 12 months and uh you know that
was just on 50 grand that i'd put in we
spent all of that money and so what
happened is the company was growing and
profitable
but we were doing like
three percent profit margins and so
we've gotten down to the point where we
had i think like ten to twelve thousand
dollars in the bank and like that was
growing
but we were like expenses were
increasing by so much more that uh like
our days worth of expenses was getting
shorter and shorter and so that got uh
super scary you guys want to know okay
random story
so uh
i i think you all know andrew warner
um
mixer i was at a mixergy meetup in san
francisco like he would do these scotch
nights
and uh
uh after one of those
like we i think we were walking out of
the building and he's like dude you know
it kind of pulls me aside he's like dude
you seem super stressed
and
and i was like yeah like and i kind of
told him the financial situation and we
were like our bank balance was growing
but you know you're like now paying all
these people and you have no money and
uh
um
so i told him about that and and he said
okay here's what we're gonna do
i'm gonna wire you 25 000 tomorrow
you're going if you need the money spend
it do whatever you eat whatever you want
with it whenever you feel right like pay
me back
um or if you don't need it like just put
it in a savings account like just let it
be in you know like an insurance blanket
for you and then uh wow you know why
did you know him well anything if he
uh we'd hung out in person i think twice
before so i knew him a little bit
on the podcast
and we were gonna say the only thing
what oh the only the thing he said is
like if you do decide to raise funding
like convert that into you know like
i'll be the first person in for that um
if not what a smart move
okay but i think that's a good move
the thing that he said is the only thing
that will piss me off on this is if you
ever try to pay me interest on it
like don't try to make this a loan in
any way and so i held onto the money
it sat in the bank account for like
eight or nine months
uh we grew our bank account to the point
that we had plenty of savings in the
bank and all of that and i wired the
money back and like
uh andrew is forever one of those people
where i'm like thank you just because he
pulled me aside and was like dude you
seem stressed and he was like here let
me loan you a security blanket that's
one of the coolest stories i've heard
that's frankly that's amazing
shout out to andrew we gotta have it we
gotta have everyone now just for that
story uh we've joked about it before but
we should have them on for sure
because if he's done it to you he's
probably done like some weird stuff like
that to a bunch of people so that's he's
probably has some interesting stories
yeah i mean he knows everyone too so
he's he's i'm looking at your guys's
revenue chart there's a huge spike every
november what did you do is like a black
friday deal or what what causes this
huge yeah we can talk about whether
that's a good idea or not
um so early on right when you need cash
uh the thing that you do in sas is you
push annual plans right because you have
this uh cash flow problem and so we
started pushing annual plans as part of
our black friday sale you know to bring
forward a bunch of that cash um
and so we kind of just kept doing that
and then what it did is it aligned a
whole bunch of uh
um renewals you know annual payments
right around that same time so it just
keeps getting bigger and bigger right
until it gets the point that you're
pulling in like four and a half million
dollars in a single month um you're also
getting all the churn at the same time
so i don't know that
like
like we're not gonna keep doing it by
the way there's so many things like that
in business that i'm like
we're doing this i can't really say if
it's a good idea or a bad idea i wish i
could
but we're just we're just gonna keep
doing it for now and then like i just
kind of feel like it's gonna work out
but i could totally see that like
we didn't need to do any of this or that
this like long term is hurting us more
than the short term gain
what's an example um like in my d2c
business as far as kind of thinking
about this is uh
we do this model that like drops new
products all the time every single week
we drop new products and it's great
because it causes this sales spike but
it also puts you on this treadmill of
new products that you have to release
every week and that means you gotta do
photo shoots of those products every
week and then that means that you have
to have inventory whether you sold your
previous inventory or not you got to buy
new inventory like most brands they
don't do that they only buy your
inventory when they're out of the old
stuff so even though inventory sucks out
cash you know it's like
well it's i'm buying it because i
there's i'm sold out we're not even
doing that but on the other hand it's
creating like that when i look at his
chart it's creating this spike every
single week and i'm like okay so that's
good but these other three things are
bad and like i don't know how to weigh
these against each other because they're
like
in different categories that speak
different languages and on different
time scales so it's just hard to hard to
know if this is like a dumb idea or a
bad idea or a good idea um
i think
the thing to look for in that is uh
something that served you before might
not serve you now so like that served us
really well for a period of time because
it brought in this cash you know and you
could tell the team like hey like
payroll is good we're set for a long
time
and it gives that level of comfort and
also like in the early days churn is
often high in a business just because
you don't have very many mature accounts
and so locking that in is really good
but then if you get to this long
you know much later in the business
you're like look we're on accrual
accounting it we don't really care we
have plenty of cash in the bank like
this spike at this time doesn't make a
difference right and so just i'd watch
for those things where it's like this
served the business well for a while and
it doesn't anymore
who built the early version
um so i did all the design and front-end
development um and then i hired uh
freelancers to
um you know write the rails back end and
then that went okay
and then it went much better when i
hired a long-time friend named david to
come on and like
full-time uh build it but that was two
years in and you know it was making
enough it was making enough money to pay
him
no that was where i paid him out of the
50 grand that i put in
which was like our our savings and
everything
seems like a pretty good return i mean
50k and you're able to get that built
and turns into what it is now or at
least it got you to enough revenue to
pay people
yeah
yeah and uh
i mean it's wild what you can do when
one you're doing a lot of the design and
code yourself you know so you gotta
count that in the cost but um
but but yeah and then you just fund it
with
that makes it sound easier than it is
but you know you fund it with growth
simple not easy yeah simple not easy so
so sean nathan he's got this blog post
called like how to how to build well
yeah i think it's called laughs we have
another blog post
ladders of wealth he's got this actually
this other great blog post called um the
billion dollar creator i think it's
called or the billion dollar blog
let's do the billion dollar let's do the
billion dollar one all right i'm sorry
to sam i don't know where you're going
with that
well well i just want to say
so this whole thing about transparency
so nathan i don't think you publicize
this but i'm on this email list
and every month or week probably month i
think he sends out dude it's the
craziest [__] i've seen he sends out his
entire net worth and you could see like
how much cash he has how much uh like
which stocks he owns of and of how much
uh like his angel investments like you
see his entire fi all of his finances i
gotta get on this list that sounds
amazing
it's all the content that i wanted to
that i wanted like other people to
publish like sam you talk about fat fire
and like that's it fantastic subreddit
um
and i just want like more of those
conversations because i've written a ton
about people who have or like how to get
from
say like zero to a hundred thousand
dollars
uh on the internet you know that's you
mentioned my book authority that's what
that was um
but like once you kind of get to the
point where you're making a hundred
thousand two hundred thousand or more
online
like people don't talk about
what you do with their money because you
know if you do that someone's like oh
you know like there's sam just bragging
about how much money he has again or you
know something like that and so i was
like okay i'm gonna make a private
newsletter and i just charge people 100
bucks like just to filter out the
the uh
anyone who's going to complain about it
i guess or say that i'm bragging and
then just say i'm going to write about
all the stuff that i wish i knew when i
made like my first 250 grand uh online
and so the way that i i describe your
blog or that email is it's kind of like
face tattoos and cornrows i think it's
super cool when other people have them
but i don't want it
like yeah you know not not for me but i
i it's cool when others have them
there's only 200 people on that list so
it's it's a small group right now
dude i don't know man but sean what was
your question about well i wanted to
kind of walk through the the framework
here so you have this blog post that's
kind of like i know you worked on that
for a while uh kind of shaping your
thinking here
and um and then we also have sam who's
somewhat bearish on the idea of the
creator economy thinks he's kind of
overhyped over over buzzword and you're
mr creator economy in a way uh nathan so
i think this would be this this might be
good um but let's walk i don't think our
opinions are opposites by the way i
would i would say probably our opinions
are not opposites yeah for the sake of
argument let's just uh let's just walk
through so you basically have these four
rules of building
a billion dollar audience so um i guess
like first why did you even want to do
this uh like kind of like what got you
interested in this and then let's walk
through the four yeah
so the article asks a question like the
whole premise of it and that is
what is the most profitable
uh place to direct attention right so
everything we do right we're recording a
podcast now whatever you're doing on on
tick tock or if you're a movie star or
everything else right you have attention
and brands want it they're willing to
sponsor you know all this stuff and so
it's like okay
you have the opportunity to point that
attention somewhere what's the most
profitable
way to do that long term
because you look at people um
you know maybe who are taking
sponsorships right
five grand uh you know to sponsor the
newsletter or you know 500 bucks for a
sponsored um
uh instagram post or anything like that
and
that's actually not that profitable and
we when you dive in you learn that the
most profitable thing to do
is to create your own product
and to drive that attention to something
where you actually build equity long
term so it's like a longer uh article
talking about that but like the richest
movie stars you know like take jessica
alba for example
right
she has made a lot of money from movies
but the bulk of her wealth is from
starting a company using you know being
the spokesperson for her own company um
and then my other favorite example would
be ryan reynolds um who
you know right he's doing ads for other
people and probably getting paid a
million bucks here 10 million dollars
there you know that kind of thing and at
some point he goes like forget that
i'm going to buy my own companies with
mint mobile and aviation gin and i'm
going to be my own spokesperson so i
don't get cash i get equity
and so you know you just watch this
process of people doing it over and over
again and that's actually my hypothesis
with convertkit
right of
i have attention on the internet through
running a blog
and a newsletter and all of that
how do i want to monetize it
sponsorships ebooks membership a bunch
of things i'm like nope i want to
monetize it through convertkit building
a sas company like that's my
version
of the billion dollar creator so that's
the whole premise of the article and
it's like uh
so you have a couple examples so okay so
rule number one is you have to build
more than a personal brand so what does
that mean you give the example of
jessica alba
of mark from primal kitchen so what what
is the nuance here it's like it's not
just your face your name you need to
actually
create a brand around uh
around your lifestyle or your interest
is that it by the way sean primal
kitchen is
the sugar-free ketchup company that i
like so this guy named mark he's like
kind of looks like the 65 year old
version of me but like even more jacked
and he like has a health and health blog
and he starts selling ketchup and he
sells that for like 300 million dollars
yeah so i mean what mark did uh
with uh amy's blog was called mark's
daily apple and it was like the leading
you know like paleo
kind of health blog in that space and a
blog like that you know
when he was doing this 2006 2010 that
kind of thing you can make a million
bucks a year off of that blog and he was
right but
you play that forward um and that's it's
all about him all about his name
um all that write his name is in the
name of the site
but i mean you can build substantial
wealth that way what he didn't said is
he started primal kitchen you know
kickstarted this whole brand
by saying i have the most popular site
in the space let me you know make these
uh paleo-friendly
uh ketchup mayonnaise that kind of thing
and then he goes you know how big his
audience was do you know how big how
much traffic he had at the time it
wasn't huge huge like it was
like ours yeah thousand subscribers on
the email list maybe so a hundred
thousand kind of like trusted audience
size
to kick kick off this yeah you gotta
remember audiences were a lot smaller
like even just 2015 2012 like that kind
of time frame but yeah then he sells it
to craft for 200 million dollars
you can't sell a blog
to like a blog doesn't sell for 200
million you know uh like all of these
things and the crazy thing is he still
owns the audience right the thing that
that kicks out of this whole product he
still owns he can sell off the that
whole brand talking to him at a
conference you know he's just on to the
next thing figuring out what he wants to
do next he didn't have to sell his his
name and whole identity with it uh and
craft is so thrilled with their purchase
kylie cosmetics is probably the biggest
one that people know about because you
have tons of attention through instagram
tick tock whatever the tv show whatever
and uh
instead of just saying hey i'll you can
pay me because people used to say wow
you have to pay twenty five thousand
dollars for a tweet from kim kardashian
or
then if that was twenty five thousand
then it went up to like two hundred
fifty thousand then two million dollars
for an instagram post from is it two
million dollars it got it got up to that
range where it was like either hundreds
of thousands or low millions to get like
an actual like endorsement post from
from one of them
and um
and so then you know cool you can make a
lot of money doing that you're right you
can you could stack up quarter million
dollars at a time
but kylie cosmetics was a billion dollar
brand so i was like well who wants to
who wants to pay me
to promote their products well it's
mostly like skincare products makeup
products or for kim kardashian it's her
shapewear like you know like uh and
khloe kardashian it was like you know
fashion or whatever so chloe launches
true american jeans
uh kim kardashian launches i think it's
called what was it
skims skims is it like the shapewear
brand dude sean you're on top of it keep
going kylie kylie cosmetics
kanye yeezy shoes right layers like
they all turned to say who whoever is
the most willing advertiser
actually you become my competitor and
i'm going to launch my own brand my own
equity and have my own equity in this
thing and there's a guy in the nba who
gets made fun of for this which is this
guy lavar ball i don't know if you guys
know this guy but basically he has three
sons all three wanted to make it to the
nba and this guy's this like loud mouth
guy they got like a reality show around
them because they're sort of like the
like you know basketball version of the
kardashians there's three brothers and
like a a kind of an overbearing parent
who is like
architecting their business strategy and
when they were gonna the guy was gonna
get picked second in the draft and nike
offered him a contract in adidas and
instead he created big baller brand and
you know triple b he created his own
shoe line and like the shoes kind of
sucked and like you know he didn't have
the full business plan and people were
making fun of him for like oh wow you
turned down a guarantee 10 million
dollars from nike to like launch this
thing 10 million a year or whatever and
it's like
actually that was the right move now
maybe his execution was slightly poor
but that was actually the right move and
and
a lot of these nba players would have
been better served had they done that
themselves well how's it going now the
shoe thing
so the shoe thing's not going good
basically the guy they had running it
like was like kind of stealing from them
so they fired him that was like a black
mark on it the second brother never made
it to the nba so that was like a little
bit of an issue um
the first brother kind of underperformed
his potential at that time
uh and actually now that it would have
worked because the youngest brother the
one who was like the the the one who's
kind of like he was kind of like a
a [__] boy a little bit he's you know
he's like had a goal you know like a
diamond grill had like a lambo at 15 and
was like you know he was kind of off the
reservation he actually turned out to be
the best one he's actually a star player
and if they had kind of built it
properly around him it probably would
have done a lot better so i um nathan
you'll get a kick out of this so like
three or four weeks ago we did this
thing where we said we're gonna give
five g's to one or two three people who
take our clips download it post it on
tick tock and get views there's this kid
who did it and i don't remember how many
views he got but like our hashtag i
think got 30 million views in like two
weeks and this guy accounted for a lot
of them and multiple of his videos got a
thousand or sorry a million views one
video got so big that we drove thirty
five thousand new members to the
subreddit
and they complained and i was like
reached out to this kid i'm like who are
you and he replies back with like
michael you michigan.org or something
like that or dot you or whatever it is
and
i'm like wait dude are you in college
and like he calls me and i face time
with him and he's in his dorm room and
he's young he's in still in college he's
doing his universe i think and and he's
really cocky not in a bad way but he's
like he's got hutzpah he goes man i knew
i was going to do this i wanted to prove
to you guys that i could do it i want
you to pay me money to do this now and
i'm gonna do this for other people and
we're gonna change the media game and
i'm gonna raise money and i was like
okay hold on dude hear me out and he
goes i'm gonna i'm gonna go raise money
for this thing uh do you wanna invest i
go bro listen you do not wanna raise
money for this here's what you should do
you are so talented at this that don't
raise money for this but get it big and
start launching other stuff on top of it
and if you want to raise money raise
money for that stuff
and own all he owns this thing called
like um i forget what it's called future
but he's got like eight handles now that
have like
a million something follow followers i'm
like no no don't raise money for this
thing man own that forever and that's
your piggy bank and your audience raise
money for like this other thing that you
want to do and funnel it through there
but don't sell that thing because i
raised a little bit of money for my
thing which was like that and i i don't
regret it because i got the outcome that
i wanted but i do regret it because it
definitely hit you're massively
handicapped because of it yeah one
that's
i think such a good point because you
can
have that platform to launch whatever
you want in the same way that you know
marxism can use his platform to then go
launch the next thing right he probably
has contracts that say he can't compete
in the exact same space but he could do
a fitness thing or he could do something
else
right you have the great point
well i was gonna give an example conor
mcgregor is doing this pretty
brilliantly in the ufc so like uh the
ufc gets knocked a lot because of they
have like low fighter pay right like the
the percentage of revenue that they give
to their fighters is way lower than
other sports nba is 50
nfl's like 50
ufc is like i don't know 15 or 20 so the
fighters are
you know they go out there they get
their you know face beating in and
they're they're they'll make twenty
thousand dollars off that fight or forty
thousand dollars or eighty thousand
dollars and then they only get to do
that two or three times a year so it's
like a pretty brutal sport for low pay
what conor mcgregor did was
instead of selling the attention try to
try to make money as his kind of like
service fee
he created a brand around literally
every part of his lifestyle so he's like
all right this thing's gonna get me
famous
but then okay what am i famous for
people like my suits at the press
conferences cool i'm launching a suit
brand okay um i'm irish i'm going to
launch an irish whiskey irish whiskey i
think just sold for i don't know if you
know samus
yeah like he walked away with a hundred
exactly then he's like um cool uh i'm
super fit because i'm a ufc fighter my
body's amazing
here's my p90x program it's called
mcgregor fast you can you can buy my
program and subscribe to that and you
can get fit with me oh you're getting
fit and um guess what else do i do i
recover okay here's a recovery spray
that i spray on my leg that's like you
know like makes my leg uh recover faster
after workouts and the guy is literally
just selling like every piece of his
lifestyle as a independent brand like uh
you know i think at one point he was
thinking about launching a sports
betting exchange it's like what is the
best business who wants to pay me oh
draftkings wants to pay me hmm
maybe instead of draftkings is mcgregor
kings now and i'll launch a competitor
he just he just opened up a bar called
the black ford exactly oh you know i had
good good success with whiskey what else
do we do irish stouts okay i'm gonna so
he bought a bar
not that the bar is that good it's like
a bar in his hometown your bar's not
gonna make a ton of money but then he
used that bar as the like basically the
backdrop
to film
him creating a stout and now he's going
to sell a stout as a new like alcoholic
beverage brand and uh it's kind of
amazing the guy's going to become a
billionaire
and fighting is going to be the lowest
part of his income stream is my guess
which is insane i bet you
i bet you mcconner conor mcgregor i bet
you he goes well he might make a million
he might lose a billion
i think he could uh nathan oh you're
you're worth like
uh did you reveal the valuation of your
company
uh we we raised it 200 million
okay so let's just i let's just i don't
know what the facts are but let's just
say you own 90 so you're worth 180
million dollars do you think that you
can ever spend through that
uh i would have to radically change my
lifestyle
but do you think
is that enough
yeah that's so much more than enough
i think i spend like 200 grand a year so
if that gives you an idea if you take a
like if you set aside the things like
when i'm not buying assets that's your
burn that's your actual burden it's like
200 a year so yeah it would take a lot
to
yeah to spend through uh
through that
so
we let's go let's go to this wealth
ladder thing well i i hold on there's a
point uh i'll go
so what what sean was saying about um
uh
like the trend between all of these
people is that that's what's in the rule
number two of selling products not
attention and that's the flip right so
conor mcgregor is a perfect example of
this because everyone's expecting people
to sell attention right that's the the
nascar logos plastered all over the car
equivalent of that you're like great
conor's doing that every celebrity and
so you know you expect that uh
um
everyone like
every influencer is going to do that and
the wealthiest people are the ones who
are like great
i'm going to not do that i'm going to
promote my own product
conor is the extreme example of like i'm
going to do 10 of these or something
most people are like let me do one or
two
but that's where you're going to build
this real wealth
let's just hit the other rules real
quick so rule number three drive higher
customer value through recurring or
repeat purchases so you'd rather have a
a product that you can that has
repurchase rate versus a one-off that's
the big idea there
yep
yeah and that's the thing if you just
look at the most valuable brands you see
that a lot of them are selling a product
that someone buys
many times
right yeah so you know if my first
million created an idea journal
it's probably not going to have super
high repurchase rate because your you
know one journal will last you a long
time versus if we made uh you know the
pure money deodorant and pure money
deodorant is something that you would go
through every two months then that
consumable is going to be worth more
than you know so product selection is
important here
yep and so even just going back to the
ketchup example right right you know
you're going through catch-up every
month every couple months you know
that's way better than something that uh
lasts forever right billionaires catch
up great okay so then last one uh choose
a better business model so um
what do you what are you pointing out
here with choose a better business model
yeah so there's a couple things in this
one is
uh well i'm using the example of uh
vani hari who has the food babe um so
she had
information products business she's
selling cookbooks meal plans all that
and then she teamed up with a friend of
mine derek halpern
who was also in kind of that online
business space and they went and made uh
like a health supplements company and so
it's completely different they've made
this switch from you know that business
model into
uh selling this product that people are
buying on a recurring basis that you
know the brand can be acquired
but then i think the other example
that's interesting um i love listening
to andrew wilkinson on the show
and
you know he
did his whole thing his whole thing is
using
a very cash flow positive business right
in meta lab of
they're doing agency work honestly it's
a very profitable business but it's not
value that high in the market and so
he's like okay i'm gonna take
low to medium quality revenue and use it
to go buy really high quality revenue
you know because agencies they're not as
recurring they're not
a high multiple if you want to sell the
business so it's like great i'm going to
go buy software companies or start
software companies you know and so i'm
going to trade in you know one set of
revenue for another
and then
you see this a lot in software where
someone will launch
two like you'll have two versions of the
same tool
one's like the wordpress plugin version
where it gets it done and all that but
none of those really turn into like
substantial companies
and so the ones that made it are like
optinmonster
where they built a wordpress plugin it
was okay
made millions of dollars but like it's
not
valued like a software company whereas
when they go and rebuild uh like cya
bulky rebuilt opt-in monster as a sas
platform added more features you know
they can charge a different pricing
model um all of that and
and then it's really valuable right you
have to raise money at silicon valley
evaluations you get to sell the company
at those multiples um even though it's
like fundamentally accomplishing the
same
uh
three people who i think left money on
the table you named two of them i have a
third actually you might have named all
three um
okay so you talked about ramit sethi who
you think you know maybe he's making 10
million a year in revenue selling kind
of high-end courses his audience is all
around personal finance
and he pointed out like at the time
where he had a bunch of audience and
trust in personal finance and was
advocating for a philosophy of like hey
you know low fee index fund style
investing set it and forget it um you
know saving a certain portion of your
revenue he could have built wealthfront
which just got acquired for 1.4 billion
you know yesterday or something like
that uh which was like a robo advisor
doing just that so instead of selling
courses
could have built a software product so
left left some value potentially on the
table um another one is tim ferriss
right tim ferriss has makes a ton of
money on sponsorships and ended up
making a ton of money through
investing in the right startups because
of his brand name
but
you know could he have done what joe
rogan did uh with like on it supplements
right like i think tim ferriss has a
huge trusted audience he said look i
tried every supplement and here's my
issues with them so i'm launching the
paleo ketchup i'm launching the
nootropic supplement i'm launching the
the protein powder whatever whatever he
could have picked
you know i think is is a 500 million
dollar business given the size and trust
of his audience uh but it seems like he
didn't go that path so what do you think
of that of that
oh the third was marie
uh i think you had her in here uh and
you i think you pointed out and
yeah you pointed out two things
she builds everything at her name
instead of uh building like brands that
can be dissociated from like her person
the product is
her telling you content her selling you
time and consulting or whatever else her
selling you a course
versus her creating a product based on
her belief system and you trust her so
you think this product is gonna work for
you so
but
listen to this sean you're well
not exactly but you're criticizing these
people you're doing the exact same thing
so you've got this big audience of
people who like and trust you that
shockingly trust you and do what you say
but you're building this other thing
that people are begging to know what it
is like do you think that like
uh you're you should follow your own
advice here oh totally um you know
that's why i like this article i think
it's it's an eye opener for
it pieces together a bunch of like
anecdotes and philosophies and by the
time you read it all the way through
you're like yeah of course of course i
agree with this so
i did it in a way with the fund so for
example
podcast uh podcast ad revenue i think
our first year i made like 70 000 or
something like that in podcast ads it
wasn't much it was like a very
the the value of the audience i felt was
bigger than the
the value of the trust in the audience
was bigger than the the ad revenue
and so i bet on that i was like okay
well what if i raise the fund from these
people who have been listening
and i'm not going to take any i'm not
going to do any pitch meetings i'm not
going to make a presentation i'm just
going to say hey if you trust me from
this podcast and you want to invest
alongside me in startups you can
and so now that fund is like an eight
million dollar a year investment vehicle
so if you just take the math on that
right
you get two percent of that in
management fee okay that's not that much
but then you get 20 of carry
so 20 carry means you're basically
getting 1.6 million of startup equity
that you're investing per year for free
so 70 000 in ads versus 1.6 million in
startup equity of which i get to pick
the startups and i think those startups
can you know what if that's 5x in the
next uh you know seven to ten years so
that means each year i'm getting
something like five million dollars a
year of value out of a product created
from the podcast so that's an example of
doing it example of not doing it is i do
a course
uh and the reality is i do the course
just because i i i like teaching and b i
like the instant cash flow from that
because i can go buy stupid [__] with it
so for example uh
like i wasn't i stopped teaching my
course because i just got busy doing
other [__] and then i really wanted to
go like do some random nft speculation
and i was like ah i feel stupid doing
this with my money what if i just like
did a course for you know two weeks and
then that let me go buy a board ape and
a crypto punk and whatever else okay
that sounds more fun um and so i'm like
i'm down to you know teach successions
to do that that seems like a good trade
in my head mentally but i would say
that's not actually a good use of time
and then the new thing we're building
the new product
is kind of in that boat right the milk
road isn't called sean's crypto
newsletter it specifically has
a new brand name and it has like staff
around it and it's a product that if it
works
can be big and it'll be supercharged or
kind of initially initially uh
distributed by
people who already follow me and like my
content
and then the second criticism which
nathan can address which is like
and maybe ramit would say this he's like
well but i like blogging and i don't
know anything about starting like a per
uh
a fintech company and what's the what's
your reply to that nathan
yeah i mean i think that's a great
answer and like all these people who i
like lightly pick on in my article
they're all friends and and so that's
one where like you got to choose the
business model that's right for you but
answer the question of like okay can
this audience that i have
make me a billionaire trying to have as
many examples of like if that's the
outcome that you want
you know or maybe it's not a billionaire
right because you raise money or
something else but getting on that
hundreds of millions of dollars on type
scale then it's like okay well here's
the framework that has to happen and if
you're
saying like look
you know these we listed people who have
amazing businesses right they're
complete control of their time making
millions of dollars a year you know like
absolutely no complaints there so this
is all on the case study of like how
would you do it actually one of my
favorite examples
i used um michael hyatt as an example in
this article
and he replied like he sent me an email
right after it and said like hey
we actually discovered the exact same
thing
personal brand entirely we're selling
digital products we're very tied to our
email list we're doing like sponsors and
stuff like that and we realized like oh
this business is gonna you know reach
some limits and so he then built out all
these sub businesses they built out a
journal product you know other physical
products
and realized okay how can we build
what we take what we have now and use it
to leverage um you know other
independent brands and like kickstart
and launch them and so it's fascinating
to like use someone as an example and
have them come back and be like you're
spot on
in describing our business but you're
actually two years like you were spot on
two years ago we realized the same thing
we're fixing it and now like everyone
will see the result a little while from
now and so
uh
yeah if people want this path you know
that's that's the way to go about it how
big is this how many notebooks does this
guy sell
uh i don't know that i have
the numbers i'm trying to think what he
what he put in the article but it's uh
his other products are now bigger than
all the things that we know him for
so in the tens of millions of dollars
that's crazy um all right what were we
saying sean
i was gonna jump to the ladders of
wealth because i think this is the other
kind of nice framework that you have so
um and this is kind of like
i think some people have heard of kind
of stuff like this but i just want to
like lay out the fast version and then
we can go into whatever's whatever's
interesting from this so you have this
image of uh of a series of ladders and
it's not like one ladder that you just
go up up and up it's basically like if
you use if you choose this method of
wealth creation your ladder can be this
high but if you choose this method of
wealth creation it can go one rung
higher or it can go two runs higher or
four rungs higher depending on which one
you choose so here's here's how it works
so it's basically the lowest ladder the
smallest ladder is you're selling time
for money so that's having a job or
being uh yeah having a job basically
then there's your own service business
so this might be like an agency you're
charging by the project you have some
clients you charge some hourly rate
whether you're you know it doesn't
matter if you're like making logos for
some company or you're a lawyer you're
actually in the same boat you have a
service business with clients you charge
an hourly rate
then there's product side productized
services which is
um
it's giving a given example of a product
of productizing yes so the example would
be
let's say i charge 100 an hour to redo
the copywriting on your website
you know and so i'm i'm doing that or i
say for a thousand dollars one time you
can buy it with a credit card you know i
will go and rewrite your site you know
or write you one whole landing page um
and so there's a couple really important
things there uh one the purchase is
being made without me talking to you
like if i'm charging a hundred bucks an
hour we'll probably have a conversation
you're like we're planning that um
second thing is it's pre-packaged
so you know exactly what you're buying
and then the the third thing is that the
time and money are totally disconnected
so if i get better and better uh if i
hire people any of that right like i'm
not having to sit there for 10 hours and
do it
and so there's a bunch of these skills
that they have to learn to do the
productized service
an example a simple example we i think
ryan beagleman came on the pod long time
ago and he talked about drop servicing
which was a version of this so like the
the example he was given is like there's
these products that are like um
you pay
thirty dollars and i'll draw a picture
of you you and you give me a picture of
you and i'll draw you as a simpsons
character or like you can send this as a
gift so somebody loves the simpsons you
can give me a photo of them i'll draw it
as sims character you get it
so it has all the elements you talked
about self-serve you come in has a
predefined price you just click a button
and you pay
um you get a defined product end product
out of it so we're kind of both clear on
the bargain and then third you don't
know how long it takes me you don't know
how much it costs me i don't have to do
the work myself so with a lot of these
character services it's like it just
gets piped to a you know person in the
philippines who's an artist they take
the gig they submit it they get seven
dollars the the service keeps you know
whatever twenty three dollars and uh and
it's all done so that's like an example
of a productive service
and uh by the way isn't there like a
facebook group called production who
runs that there's a guy running that's
pretty interesting
yeah we talked about him
uh yeah great name
um
green felt maybe or something like that
so so what he does is he's got this
facebook group and the reason i like is
so niche but it's actually pretty
valuable for if you're in that niche so
he has this facebook group called
productized uh
services or something like that
productized businesses and um
[Music]
and what he was doing was he would just
show an example so he'd say oh look this
is a real estate agent and before here's
how it used to work you know here's
their page here's their face call them
up become a client blah blah blah and
he's like oh sorry
that's not a good example it's i make
what i design websites i can code
anything you can hire me as a freelancer
and then he changed it to a product i
service which is you're a real estate
agent you need a website for your
company i make real estate agent
websites come here pick one of the six
templates push go i'll give you a
website um and i'll charge you a fixed
fee of 250 or 500 to give you that
website and so it's basically a way of
productizing a um a service you know
what the best name that i've ever heard
for that is jack butcher who's our
friend and he has this course
it's got it's a beautiful it's called
build once sell twice it's so good
it's such a good name
i took the course yeah
did you love it yeah i loved it just
because everything jack does is done so
well so you know uh
he could you know write me a birthday
card and i would be like wow i love
birthday cards now it's like do i really
love birthday cards or do i just love
jack butcher i think i just love jack
butcher actually
yeah his ability to take something and
like distill it down to the absolute
essence uh and like build one cell twice
is that like it's selling products you
know you're saying okay i can make this
thing a single time and and then sell it
as many times as i want which everyone
talks about the upside of that of like
oh this is going to be amazing right i
can build this and sell it a bunch of
times no one talks about the downside
that like
it's so freaking hard to do the first
like to make the first one you know
whereas if i'm building a one-off thing
like using websites for example like
okay i'm supposed to build a website for
sam he's paying me 2000 bucks like i
build this out it's not that hard i can
use my skills to do it the product
version is like building a website
builder you know that's incredibly hard
and so you have this like trough for a
long time where you're not going to make
money in the short term but the
like the leverage is incredible
how old are you now
31.
so you're 31. as long as i've known you
we've known each other since we're both
like 23 24
you've always pretty much been the same
where you were pretty calm
very patient i would say patient would
probably be the best word to describe
you and there's been a lot of times i
remember in 2014 or something like that
i didn't have much money but i hollered
at my really rich friend and i was like
man nathan is doing like a hundred grand
a month like in revenue this thing's
gonna be big you should try to invest
and maybe i could broker a deal and you
would and uh if i did that then i met
you you probably had a ton you've also
probably had a ton of people who were
trying to buy the company for a
life-changing amount of money and you've
probably had loads of other um
opportunities so my question is how have
you stayed pretty calm and also
incredibly patient throughout all this
patience is something i struggle with
sean was telling you about uh how he
launches like a new does a new drop
every week and like and i i think that
that's rooted in like oh but we need the
numbers to go up this week
and like you got caught and i've done
this i do the same thing where i'm like
but it's not growing now and i need to
so how have you done so patient and
long-term focused
well i think part of his personality and
you're right that like uh patient and
relentless are probably two things you
could use to describe me back then uh
and now
but i think
a lot of the ideas that are in some of
these articles or that i try to write
about
is really in building this one thing so
i think about
uh
what analogy that like is strip malls
versus skyscrapers let's say we're
getting into real estate development and
we've got a piece of land and you're
trying to decide okay what what should
we build on it and so you want to make
money quickly and so you build like uh
you know first little office building or
something you got like a radio shack
there now you're making you got a little
bit of cash flow coming in you know you
want to expand so you build another you
know add on to that now we've got a
subway and we're we've built it out and
we've got a little strip mall or a
shopping center and that's like we're
gonna use up our land uh each time we're
expanding horizontally
and so we're you know launching a new
product the version of this is the like
the blogger podcaster someone who's like
i've got my ebook my membership site my
whatever other thing that i'm doing
you know i keep adding and each one
makes a little bit of money
my approach on everything is the
skyscraper model of like i'm gonna do
one thing and i'm gonna keep pouring
everything into that and just keep going
taller and taller and taller and make
some and so like convertkit is my
attempt at a skyscraper and like in the
billion dollar creator article
it's all about people i think who are
building those skyscrapers you've not
you've not always done that actually i
think and i think that that's a good
strategy but i i would actually say it's
pretty cool that you've not always done
that and i'll give you an example but
the reason why it's cool is because like
you're flawed and you do you you
definitely have you're you're even
though you're incredibly patient
long-term thinking like maybe it's not
rooted in this probably but like there
are some examples for example like
you've done a bunch of book launches
you've launched like eight or nine
things that's that have sucked uh you
did this great twitter thread were you
well no he did this twitter that's very
sucked
yeah he goes here's the nine things that
i've created that were horrible
no
he had a threat i don't know if he used
the word suck maybe he said fail
yeah flopped or something like that so
yeah
this is something else right like we all
want to jump in and build the most
perfect product uh and you can't do that
because there's all of these skills you
have to learn like that's the point of
this ladders of wealth creation article
is that
like business and building wealth is the
combination of like a thousand little
skills and if you try to do it all at
once
you know like you're going to fail and
so that's like in these ladders
the one point that i'm trying to make is
that the like you know i put
marketplaces and social networks you
know and at the top of the hardest
ladder and then just below that is sas
because if you think about the number of
skills that you have to know
in order to do that
like sam what was uh the first product
you sold online
um
i
uh well there was two it was liquor so i
sold alcohol on the internet and then i
also created a guide on how to how to
find a roommate in san francisco
okay so that guide like do you remember
as you were trying to figure out how to
collect payments for that or like how to
put together a page that would sell it
that's why he was at the gumroad meetup
yeah
i ended up using gumroad because it was
so stressful i couldn't figure out i was
like well i was like i remember going to
shopify i'm like well does shopify let
you sell pdfs how does that work
so yeah one of those things right you're
trying to figure out how to do
like okay how to collect money on the
internet is something you have to learn
and now we're just like we could we
could rattle off a whole bunch of ways
right but
someone's starting out saying hey i want
to get into this they don't know how to
collect money on the internet they don't
know how to
write headlines they don't know how to
collect email subscribers why that even
matters right all of these things
and so i think the best way to do it is
to learn
through a bunch of these other little
products right and so that was like
basically what you're seeing all the way
along with the ebooks and everything
else is me learning all of the skills
that ended up culminating and being able
to build conversations
yeah that's right
and then the other thing is
like if i say i only focus on convertkit
like that's not fully true because
i like to have
contrast in my life i think that's
something that helps and so like we we
started off you know riffing on some
real estate stuff and the reason that i
like it is because you spend all your
time sitting
in front of a computer
and so
doing something tangible like airbnb or
something in the real world like to me
is the opposite because i get to
actually go see a real property i get to
uh
you know
um
visit in person it's a totally different
experience
my friend um sean blanc says uh if you
work with your mind you should rest with
your hands
and that's i like that idea
of like just doing something that's the
opposite and so i think if you give
yourself these little indulgences of
like
uh
buying a house in airbnb
or starting like a one-off paid
newsletter that you run on autopilot or
sean what you're doing where you're like
run out and make a course and then
you're like okay that was fun
i think that can be a creative outlet
that helps you focus on the main thing
rather than saying like oh i'm going to
go create 10
main things
when you've been creating convertkit
um
let's say that either you've sold the
company and you still want to like do
interesting things or you're 21 or 25
years old and you want to start
something what interesting opportunities
or problems that need to be solved have
you discovered where you're like
i can't do that now but it'd be pretty
cool if someone like someone could
totally get into the blank and do blank
yeah okay this is uh honest but a
terrible answer to your question because
of the night because i also did it right
um is
as we were doing email marketing you
know and running the newsletters for
like james clare and tim ferriss and
everyone else
um the thing that i wanted to do is then
get into commerce of like okay we have
this whole side of it right where
we're sending all the emails have the
connection to the fans now i want to
build um
the
like the credit card processing and i
want to get a cut of everything that
they sell um and so then i realized like
oh
and that was always the answer uh
actually if someone's like if you
weren't doing convertkit what would you
do now i always said i'd go start a gun
road competitor
and then the nice thing is there's that
synergy there so it's like okay i went
and started a gun road competitor called
convertkit commerce it's in the same
product
so it's like
uh
both a realistic answer and probably not
very satisfying for you because it's
totally different gumroad has been
around for a long time now
up until recently they pretty much had
never done anything to change it
um and no one is competing with them
but
there's a downside it doesn't make that
much money like i actually don't know
what it makes anymore but as of a couple
or a few years pass like he would tweet
out his revenue and like it was really
hard to build a business where he was
making like four percent of someone's
like ten dollar pdf
you know what i mean
so that's why you have to build a build
a better business model right and so if
you look at something and say
how could we improve that business model
the thing that i saw in that is like
okay
uh what if
we had another product alongside it that
we sold it's right so for convertkit we
make money off of uh your email
subscription
and so i now have these two things that
go hand in hand and so
uh the commerce side is really good
because now like we're able to for every
one of our customers right who's selling
products we're able to make a little cut
of that and they don't feel like they're
paying us anything extra because it's
just a bit of a credit card processing
fee um and then it also reduces our
churn because anyone who's selling
through convertkit commerce
um
right they're now like convertkit is
paying them
rather than uh the other way around and
so we saw a radically low return so i'd
argue that like gumroad by itself or you
know the gumroad competitor that i
wanted to start by itself you're right
it's not that good of a business model
but when you pair it with convertkit and
make the creator marketing platform this
is turning into a sales pitch but you
get the idea that i'm trying to make um
it's the like the combination of those
two things that then makes it a
fantastic business model and so you have
to look at okay
this is working i want to go after this
in whatever space it is and then take a
step back and say okay what are the
flaws in the business model what other
products do i pair it with what other
audience do i targeted against you know
any of those things that actually makes
it
a compelling business instead of like
an average business
and
do
do you actually are you still hands-on
with
convertkit or are you i know you're the
ceo but do you have someone helping you
run it or are you still the guy in
charge
no i'm uh way too hands-on uh the thing
that people don't tell you in startups
is that like the growth that you see is
a whole bunch of stacked s-curves you
know of like you figure out things that
work and it takes off and then it levels
out and you got to figure out the next
uh plot or like the next uh stage of
growth and so i'm
uh
very hands-on like we've had a few
executives leave over the last year uh
just a lot of change and so
i'm like completely into recruiting new
executives
uh working with the team to design the
next version of the product and so yeah
i'm not the the like
uh case study of what you should do for
the perfect execution on you're not the
four-hour work week
i i'm not the four-hour work week
[Laughter]
do you grind i mean i know you got like
18 kids
uh
no three yeah
i know i i just because as long as i as
long as i remember you i think your
oldest are like you had your oldest when
you were young and so i always would
tease i'm like what do you have like 40
kids now um
[Laughter]
and uh but you you are you grinding
right now or do you have is it a 40 hour
work week
uh it's uh it's right now it's a lot
more than a 40 hour work week but it's
interesting of trying to structure that
around
like kids
you know of
it's a lot of like
waking up early
you know or like this weekend uh we're
headed out for our team retreat like
meeting everyone up in person so i'm
leaving saturday morning so like this
morning when my kids woke up early i
like
we went out of the house and like spent
two or three hours together
you know before because i know i'm gonna
work all day and and then be gone all
next week so
uh
yeah i don't work a crazy amount but at
least like 50 to
55 hours a week is probably what i aim
for
so i don't know if that counts as
grinding but it's definitely not not
relaxing
it's in the middle
yeah in the middle i think of grinding
and neck grinding
um
what do you think sean uh i think it's
great you know i think convert i'm a
user so i uh and i i complained to
nathan all the time i'm like i'm paying
too much for convertkit and he's like
you do complain about that and he was
good and i just point out how much money
you make yeah he was like um but you
know email's like making you all this
money and i'm like yeah but i just feel
like email's free and like this should
be free and i was like i was like can i
just get this for free and he's like
well you know like let me know what you
think is you know you're very very
patient with me and it was sort of like
you know because i was like i was like i
don't know i told ben i was like ben go
find like what we should use instead of
convertkit and then kind of like search
for a couple products and then he was
like well you know like they're all kind
of worse but there are some cheaper
options you want worse but cheaper
and i was like oh [__] i gotta choose
worse but cheaper wait what's your
what's your what's your bill every month
i think i pay like 400 a month maybe
more i don't even know uh that's what
you're and how much money do you make a
month well see it's not about that right
like it's more those are two separate
things i feel like because because the
email directly doesn't make me that much
money uh it's like got it through the
email i build the audience and then
through the audience if i launch a
product or a course or whatever yeah
that makes a bunch of money but that's
separate work i gotta go do with a
separate set of costs that go into that
and so we actually did we were like oh
should we switch and then i kind of
respected that nathan wasn't just like
uh whatever it takes to stay you know
here you go free i was like i was like
uh okay the fact that he didn't do that
tells me like he knows the value of his
thing
and um as much as i hate that i'm you
know not getting this like free discount
or whatever
i respect that and so i stuck with it
nathan are you mormon
no i'm not dude you got the big mormon
energy man
[Laughter]
i mostly just hear from you sam
you've never heard that from anyone else
i mean you live in idaho you you you had
kids at 21 like you're you work hard
you're honest it seems like you don't
party you got hardcore mormon energy
mountain dew all the time
yeah gotta avoid the caffeine uh
no sean what i was gonna say
is uh that
what what's funny is
so like tim mcgraw and arnold
schwarzenegger both have convertkit
newsletters and they pay full price and
they don't ever give me [__] about it
but then it's the it's like the internet
influencers where they're like i should
get this for free you know and i'm like
no so it's fascinating because we've had
that a lot over the years right of
people saying like hey what discount can
you give me do you know how famous i am
and kind of what's fun is getting into
uh i separate them from internet famous
and actual famous and the more you've
gotten into the actual famous space the
more it's very easy to say like no man
here's the value that we provide
and and i think i was giving you a hard
time because you had just done a thread
like two weeks earlier about your paid
newsletter that was making like 50 or
100 grand a month
i can't remember if i like linked you to
the same thread but that's what i wanted
to do in the twitter dms so how big is
how big is arnold's list
oh we can't say those numbers but he's
uh still relatively small who's whose
list is bigger his his list are my list
my list is not very big but uh his
experience i think it could be the same
thing as arnold no way
that [__]
you don't have a favorite little
uh like business model synergy
that weakly
[Laughter]
so he was on like it's fun like as he
goes around promotes his newsletter
right because he goes on like jimmy
kimmel and he's talking about his email
newsletter which is is always fun um
yeah i go on indie hackers dude
but uh
when like a business model thing that's
funny is when one convert a customer
links to another to grow their list so
like when tim ferriss links to
uh arnold's list and said like hey you
know go sign up for arnold's list it
added you're like
40 000 subscribers
and it's just like our cut just goes
up you know just one customer just
referred to the other but now
anyway it's a fun dude you got to write
a blog post like the best way to grow
your list partnerships here's like a
list of like interesting people to
partner with
so uh i have a vp of growth opening uh
do you want to come
come here
for morning brew actually as we
discussed last episode
yeah last episode morning brew offered
me a job too there you go it's actually
like a great power move is to just offer
uh staff writer jobs or staff jobs to
ceos of other companies just to like
flex on them
okay you know i heard things are tough
um just so you know we're we're always
there's always a home for you here
so let's just say
of mailchimp
like the like
a month into starting the hustle um i
like we wrote blog posts whatever and we
were i was trying to hire writers and i
saw this awesome article and i and i
don't remember where it was but the
author was nelly bowles i think her name
is b-o-w-l-b-o-w-l-e-s
and now she's like a really famous new
york times person and i think like even
when i found her she was actually at the
new york times but like had just done a
one-off piece for this small magazine
and i emailed her i'm like you are so
good would you love to interview for a
position at my company like we're
looking for bloggers and she was like
that's cute but no thanks
and uh i will never forget that she told
me that's cute i've i have held this
grudge against her
for years because she said it's cute
for years
you could just imagine like the little
pat on the head and the hair tassel that
went with like
you know like
it kept me up at night like so many i
was like i'm gonna how am i gonna get
revenge and i don't have a good way but
that was like eight years sam's like
arya stark before bed every night he
says a list of the names of the people
he needs to like get revenge on is like
nelly bowles
i definitely have you know like what
they said like i got like a bunch of
champagne bottles with people's names on
it and whenever i get back at them like
crack that champagne bottle open and
drink it like yeah i want some people's
heads on my desk that's for sure
we have a buddy on that list
not much turns out not much
yeah just don't call me cute
um just be like you know comment on one
of his instagram uh you know videos and
just be like
um
it's awesome for a beginner
just let me move on
like
you're still at it awesome
[Music]
we uh we have a buddy who is like the
nicest guy in the world like uh you know
we'll give you the shirt off his back
and uh nice to everybody kind of
strangers kind of animals kind of
everybody and you go into his house and
on his fridge he's got this like clip
art picture of a of a brand name of a
another company's logo with a target and
like kind of like a red target like a
sniper um and he's got three of them on
his fridge and i remember going over
like what's this about and he's like
oh yeah he's kind of like you know those
are my those are my competitors i just
every day when i come to the kitchen i
just want to think about you know just
sort of killing them basically and i was
like whoa there's a dark side to the uh
to mr nice guy here
do you have one of those nathan i would
bet anything nathan does not have
anything like what we're talking about
he's got you are so wrong i bet you that
he he will i don't know if he'll admit
it i bet you he hates mailchimp
oh see
i have weird feelings about mailchimp
because i have so much respect for them
and like
dude you have respected them like the
guy who killed john lennon has respect
for him it's called a love knife you
love him so much you want to kill him
that's like what it is
it's like the guy who like killed the
pope that's what you're gonna do
so you have to separate the businesses
like the business from the people so i
think that's true like one time uh i was
at a conference and ben chestnut was
speaking and so i emailed him and was
like hey man were you
i don't even know why he said yes but
it's just like like big fan of what
you've done
like all in all fairness for a
competitor trying to take as much
business from you as you can but would
you be up for sitting down and talking
and he said like yeah i have a flight at
this time so i'm checking out the hotel
so like meet me in the hotel lobby
you know and we'll chat for 30 minutes
gave you the wrong hotel love it great
power move bent chestnuts
set me on this wild views yeah it's like
you missed your flight he never had a
flight
but no he like he sat down with me and
told me all about how they launched
their free plan and all this stuff and
then the they were inc magazine's uh
company of the year this is the inc
magazine like in 5000 event
and so the editor in chief from inc
magazine comes up while we're talking
he's like hey ben great talk all of that
and uh um
he ben goes hey do you know nathan he's
trying to kill my company
and like as he introduces me to the
editor-in-chief of ink magazine and
anyway so
what would it look like if you just like
assaulted him right there
sam's gone
now he's still thinking like
like killing nelly balls with the love
knife or whatever
for the record nelly i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna do anything is this the same
person that you had the interview the
famous interview with at the new york
times or the new yorker or whatever it
was and like the interview did not go
well
it did not go is this with her
no that was uh aaron griffin
and she like came to interview me and i
don't even know why but she was fishing
for stuff and she's like so like what do
you do in the weekends like listen to
joe rogan that's what she said to me i'm
like what
like no like he doesn't even like that's
monday to friday he doesn't even have a
podcast
yeah and she was like well like because
you're like a tech bro and i'm like
first of all
most of new york times revenue is
digital you're a tech company so you
tell me what your tech friends do
and uh so anyway yeah that thing did you
storm out or or how did that end
sometimes yeah i was just like i don't
know what to say i'm out of here yeah i
i it didn't it didn't end well that's so
good
ah those interviews i've only ever had
one of those um i don't remember who it
was with but where you're like okay i i
think we're done where you can just tell
that they're like looking for some angle
and all the questions are weird but why
would anyone hate you because you're
kind of perfect
it's good that you bring that up like
just like
it's like well
it's true so i'm not sure what the
problem is yeah it's like i like this
i've got there's a lot of it's like it's
like the shower clip of biden uh the
other day when he called the the
journalist was like on the way out did
you see this clip a stupid [__] like
you know
what do you think about inflation and
biden just like in that moment was just
like he lost it he was just like yeah
great stupid son of a [__]
that's how i imagined nathan like
breaking character in like one of these
interviews
so okay sam i have a question on this
then like do you think that being so
nice in all of this and and like
everyone likes me it holds back my uh
growth as an entrepreneur and you know
uh internet so i want to be internet
celebrity
no because um a like you're happy and
it's working so i think that's like the
goal and b you actually have dropped it
a couple times so
you don't have to talk about this if you
don't want to but basically you didn't
like what sahil at gumroad did and you
called them out and it was pretty uh
it was pretty vicious and i knew that do
you know this sean what did he call him
out for dude he just like publicly kind
of [__] slapped sahil and
like for one it was crazy
so
uh so i was around as sam was talking
about i was around gumroad from the very
beginning uh i think i was the first
independent or at one point they told me
i was the first independent seller to
cross ten thousand dollars in sales on
government so like from the very very
beginning um
and uh anyway so friends with tons of
people there and like spent a lot of
time at their office and all of that and
a huge friend of sawhill's but at one
point he
like got burnt out on the company they
had to offer to buy the company
he didn't take it he laid everyone off
instead like it wound down and and like
ultimately failed but the thing is with
a platform like that they don't like
fail and disappear they just like fail
when coast and still like the software
still works and all that
and then he came back and told this
totally different story of like uh
here's how i
you know like vc is evil and i'm running
the company like in this totally new way
um here's how i run it in five hours a
week with
like two contractors
and that was frustrating but i didn't
say anything
but then when they went and raised new
money and didn't give any they they got
all the vcs to write off their equity
they got all of the team members to be
like hey it's a failed company like give
up your equity and all that as part of
it
and they went and raised a bunch of new
money and didn't
uh go back and give the original team
members like that pissed me off because
it was like i know exactly who built the
software you know like because i sat
next to them as we were talking about it
you know at their office in san
francisco and like i know they don't
have any equity and i know that you
didn't take care of them and now you're
like telling this new story and
everything so
uh yeah i guess sam i do make some
enemies on the internet and when you
said that i was like well
as i don't know sahil uh he seems like a
nice guy from my limited interactions
with him but i was like well if nathan's
saying that it's probably true yeah and
you know you could separate
the person from like the decision i've
made a bunch of bad decisions uh but i
don't think i'm a bad guy and oh me too
i've made a lot and
yeah
and so you know i i would separate the
two like because he you know probably a
nice guy i i don't know him super well
either but um
but you're right like you know the the
way he kind of got twitter famous in a
way was to come out and tell this story
of like
the kind of like it was like a fail
story that worked it was like
we were the hot thing we raised money we
had all these expectations people bet on
us it didn't work
um and so now we're in this new mode and
i've seen the light it was sort of like
you know i got baptized and now i
believe
um that this business should be done
this other way okay fair enough um and
some people really liked that they
thought it was very transparent all that
good stuff
but it was weird that like you know a
year or two later it's like i'm raising
new money at a hundred million dollar
valuation it's like wait you're back on
the that train like
weren't you kind of saying like you know
all the things that were wrong with that
model and like
yeah championing the the freedom that
you were getting and the choose your own
destiny and getting off the rat race
like
maybe i read it wrong maybe i was just
skimming and i missed the point but like
that did seem strange to me and then
like you're saying nathan like
it's kind of weird to kind of
to do that whole thing in public when a
whole bunch of people bet on you lost
money on you
and
um and are not participating in the like
you know future
and so that would leave a bad taste in
people's mouth i think so you know i
think it's fair points um
you know and i'm sure i'm sure he's got
his side of the story about why it's not
bad and why it's not that and all those
things so you know
fair enough but he's not here so i'm
just going to say my side and it seems
like that'll be the final word
uh
i mean tons of credit to
sahil afterwards because he
like he owned up to parts of it and we
had a good conversation about it and he
actually then when he launched his book
um he actually included convertkit and
the story in it which i was
really surprised so uh as far as people
who don't hold a grudge i think uh
sahil's one not
so like there's just one guy i always
call my rival and uh i'm sure from his
perspective he's either like who is this
or he's like wait why are we rivals we
we got a lot we got one just fine and in
my head this is like somebody i met in
uh when i was in college
and um
the guys got like a super ultra rich dad
like billionaire dad and uh i always
used to joke like if i ever played
basketball
there usually wasn't like another indian
guy like playing basketball so if there
ever was like the running joke and my
group of friends in college was well
sean we know who you're guarding like
you have to guard him and you need to
win your match up here like your honor
is on the line basically like we need to
know who's the better indian basketball
player on the court right now it was
just like this running joke and so that
got extended once we i started a
business with my college friends they
were like well
seems like this guy is like you know
your rival and i played into it and we
kind of made it a thing where the guy
would be like you know hanging out with
richard branson on his island and we
were like just trying to create a chip
on our shoulder underdog stories like
you know i'd be sleeping on my air
mattress that i was planning to return
to target to like save money because our
business wasn't doing any good
and if you saw this other guy like you
know sipping pina coladas with richard
branson it just felt like oh those are
the halves and we're the have-nots and
so i was like manufacturing these little
feuds or like um
i remember we did a
we when we bought bibo back we were
going to relaunch it and i gave the
scoop to this girl who was like really
nice journalist to me
um she was somebody i'd met she seemed
really nice and i was like hey do you
want this the story like i'll give you
the story about like what we're gonna do
and how it all played out she's like
yeah great so we she comes over i do the
interview it's like
literally you know we're playing patty
cake it's all good
article comes out the next day and the
headline is like just some vicious it's
like
remember bibo huh yeah that you know
that flop is back again it was just like
it was like oh my gosh
it's like disgusting
hurry
as he told
yeah if you like spinach go eat some of
the stuff that came out of shawn's teeth
it's still probably there so i felt so
backstabbed you know not no love knife
just straight knife and i remember just
being like so i never had the interview
where i walked away i had the opposite
where i felt completely and i texted her
i was like yo what the [__] because
actually the article was fine just the
headline was completely brutal it was
just making fun of us and saying like
get a load of this [__] schmuck and
um and she's like sorry like the editor
writes the headlines and he just thought
that that's what would get more clicks
like i don't have any say in that and i
was like oh so [__] you in your
profession uh was like you know where i
landed on that um i think that was my
only feud actually my other one where i
called uh what's her name uh the jake
paul of journalism was probably the
other one
taylor lorenz
yeah like i think that i actually think
it's great fuel i mean like i joke to my
wife i'm like i'm fueled on like
carbonated water and like grudges like i
think
grudges i think are like the greatest
fuel ever like isn't that like the whole
thing about being like a chip on your
shoulder like approaching what it is
like crutches is like my macros
yeah i'm just like
yeah like i gotta make sure i get my
rage in that day otherwise i just don't
feel like myself it's like ari gold i
just love firing people um so anyway i
think it's good i think rage is great
that's the key takeaway from this
episode people listen sam you do need
like a lloyd let me go manufacture some
bridges somebody yeah every
when we first met ben levy or i met him
the first time you were like well you
know sam's a little
challenging i just had to give him a
heads up don't take it personal if he
kind of fires off ari gold is actually a
great great analogy because there's no
there's no um
uh
what's it called like there's no hate
behind the words right like i'm yelling
but i love you like it has nothing to do
with how much i like you or how good i
think you are i'm just yelling because
i'm yelling
and uh so i tried to give him the heads
up but you were so zen uh this was post
post exit sam is a completely different
guy he's uh you know you're not already
old anymore
he'll come back in due time um dude
nathan thanks for coming on happy uh
happy you you're able to make it i uh i
bailed on you last week sorry and i'm
happy that we made it work this time
yeah thanks for having me it's always
fun
you wanna know
yeah
yeah um okay so if people want to follow
me online uh i'm i'm currently trying to
grow my twitter audience so you should
go follow me there
uh i'm trying to see if i can go from
i'm at fifty thousand
[Laughter]
you know i only want the most dedicated
fans who are like really no i'm just
kidding
thanks for the advice uh sean add that
to your ladder
shove that in your ladder
you know what we didn't discuss and i
don't have time now but one time sean
nathan
renamed the company convertkit to
something else and he didn't realize it
but it meant like something like it was
disrespectful to hindus hindi's
hindi plural
and it was disrespectful and he made
this huge name change and they changed
the company back to convertkit after
like 24 hours wait what was it
what was what was that
okay
i speak what is that i mean service but
in sea culture it means like selfless
service and like the highest form of
worship yeah
and so it's the whole thing like i'm
doing it i'm doing a service for you i
don't know i don't find that offensive
that's not offensive yeah there were uh
a lot of people who did find it
offensive and so yeah if we're talking
about
we talk about mistakes turns out i'm not
as easily offended
i got in trouble so uh hindus didn't
find it offensive and i actually had a
lot of people who were like
uh
that's like thought that it was awesome
or something like that um
but yeah everyone who was from the sikh
culture they were like sorry it yeah it
had a
much different meaning uh there so
anyway that was a 500 000 mistake but uh
i owned up to it so
that's the whole thing for another by
the way
that the the convertkit good name the
other thing like seven or whatever you
said not a good name
like so i think
hindu maybe can
that doesn't seem like the right name
for an email yeah conversation is a
great name that's such a good name
well so maybe it was a 500 000 mistake
that will turn out to be a multi-million
dollar win do you do you still have the
domain because we should just launch
like a um prayer uh service or like you
know like a philanthropy uh thing for
india under that i have some indian
startups that might want that name i do
have the domain there's actually two
startups one that went through y
combinator and one other uh that uh have
asked for it at one point but
i paid 340 thousand dollars for the
domain so
i'm i'm kind of hanging on to it this is
a four letter domain four letters i
don't even know how to spell that word i
spell that word
s-e-v-a
right
yeah but um it sounds like a bottled
water dude
something that you're gonna like send
emails from so i think smart move
my uh i got in trouble this morning
because i wrote so in the milk road
edition that went out this morning uh
one of the things we covered was like oh
the fed the fed had this meeting about
interest rates and how that's affecting
like the markets
and uh
and i was like
basically i put a picture up of the
committee that meets the fed open market
committee
and it's basically like
a bunch of old white people
and i was like you know and today you
know
i had a bunch of different openers that
i scrapped one was like here's a picture
from a nursing home i visited recently
oh wait no that's not right that's the
fed open market committee and i scrapped
that
and i said something else and then i was
like you know at today's elderly white
people committee and i like i had a
strikethrough and i was like no at the
fed open market committee rural
mcdonald's at like 7 a.m
and
people got mad at you it's like a seas
candy and
yeah people were like you know the skin
color has nothing to do with it i was
like yeah of course
it's a joke and it has everything to do
with my joke and like just the picture's
funny and like wait i thought we could
make fun of the fed with no
repercussions like that
there's like certain things that are
really safe to punch at and uh the fed
seems like one of the safest you know
the fed
you know the the senate like
who's who's defending their honor i
don't understand who are you is your mom
on this is your grandma on this panel
yeah some people got mad at me um i was
like you should go ahead and unsubscribe
because uh my filter is a lot looser
than that
dude nathan thank you this is awesome
yeah thanks for having me we'll have to
do it again sometime and we'll have to
hang out in austin when you get this new
property we'll come and do a workout on
the
you know on the
ranch come on let's go
sounds good challenge accepted grudge
initiated
[Music]
you